J Balvin and bad bunny made a huge  splash in Dallas Texas with the global  premiere performance of their joint  album posses and only et has the  exclusive as the phyllis headlined day  one of Univision's 40 a latino mix live  the duo took the stage for a great cause  help me raise money for those affected  by the recent shootings in El Paso Texas  and Dayton Ohio  over 19,000 Texans came together to  watch their historic performance proven  that everything is bigger in Texas  the Oasis hitmakers shared the stage  with other big names in Latin music such  as we seen en del fake sick and many  more from Dallas to Houston  Matty Natasha lit up the stage at day 2  of the live concert  kosuna Sebastiaan yatra and federal capo  also took part in the festivities  to bring the local Latino community  together and support local organizations